juries get it wrong a lot that's my own
opinion I've had situations where like
Oh My My Heaven
sake how could they have thought that
well I have a um I have a tool that I
can deal with that it's called jury
notwithstanding the ver judgment
notwithstanding the verdict I can say
there is no possible way that a
reasonable jury would have reached that
conclusion I'm following law I'm I'm
impartial
referee but it's hard to factor out my
own
emotions all right here with reaction uh
former president uh former president
Trump's legal spokesperson Alina habba
is with us all right Alina first of all
the guy is dead wrong and you brought it
up in court today on the issue of
valuation of mar Lago okay it's anywhere
between a half a billion and a billion
dollars what part of of this does he not
understand even though the essor has
told him that he should not you know uh
juxtapose the two or think they're
similar yeah you you hit the nail on the
head there Sean the reality of the
situation is that the Appel division got
it right we have a judge that has
mentioned in his order frankly not happy
with himself at this point that the tax
assessment of a given property of $18
million is absolutely not
correct given that the fair market value
of somebody which would pay for maril
laga over a billion 1.5 billion in fact
should be completely disregarded so you
go to a tax assessor and you say my
property is worth X that's what I should
pay tax on it's not going to be the fair
market value it never is the fair market
value anybody that's gone to a tax
assessor knows that in fact the Palm
Beach tax assessment Department the
authorities there put out a statement
yesterday while we were in court Court
saying what they're saying is right this
is the tax assessed value this is not
the fair market value you're conflating
the two issues and that's been our Point
all the time let me ask you I have a
copy in my hands of the the disclaimers
that the Trump organization provided to
Banks I'll read just a little of it uh
considerable judgment is necessary to
interpret Market data and develop the
related estimates of current value
accordingly the estim presented here in
are not necessarily indicative of the
amounts that could be realized upon the
disposition of the assets or payment of
related liabilities the use of different
Market assumptions Andor estimate
methodologies uh estimation
methodologies may have a material effect
on the estimated current value amounts
because of the significance etc etc you
are putting the burden where it belongs
you're saying do not trust our
valuations they can fluctuate vary
dramatically it it there is a fiduciary
responsibility of every lender they're
not going to listen to the person that
wants to borrow the money and what they
say their property's worth if they're
putting it up as collateral they have to
do their own assessment they have to get
their own appraisals or otherwise
they're not doing their job that's not
to me it's an irrelevant issue whatever
was put in these Financial disclosure
form forms exactly Sean and let me just
be very clear on this this disclaimer as
it president Trump calls it a worthless
clause which I love that saying because
I think it says it all this is a
compilation we never said it was an
audited record it is a compilation of
his assessed values as a real estate e
he is real estate he's Trump first of
all secondly if you put your house on
Trulia right now under New York State
Attorney General Leticia James for a
million and it SS for 800,000 you're in
big trouble folks and they're going to
come after you because that's not fair
and they'll disc scorge your profits
that's what this case is and it's not
right it's not right and this judge is a
nut you know I've been saying I don't
think the president can get Fair trials
in New York I don't think he can get a
fair trial in DC I don't think he's
getting a fair trial in fton County
Georgia so uh you know and then so we'll
have the trial and probably guilty
verdicts in an election year and then
meanwhile where he'd have a far better
chance on appeal that'll happen after
the election wow that sounds like uh a
problem interference that's what that
sounds what it sounds like to me yeah
all right Alena thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else